[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques années je déciderai avec
une amie de passer la journée au spa
on arrive vers 10 heures et là on
réalise que tous les transats sont déjà
occupées il y en a une centaine par deux
personnes tout le reste ce sont des
objets des livres des magazines des
serviettes de bain des peignoirs mon ami
me dit regardant on est arrivé trop tard
y a plus une place de libre
je lui dis is a key un panneau qui dit
veuillez ne pas réserver de transat ses
transats sont prévus pour des personnes
pas pour des objets donc on se choisit
de plats sains et on rassemble toutes
les affaires et on les dispose sur les
deux transats d'à côté une demi heure
plus tard un couple se rapproche de nous
l'air contrarié et sans un regard les
reverser récupère la totalité des
affaires et là on réalise qu'ils
n'avaient pas réservé deux mais quatre
transat je dis à mon ami tu vois ça
c'est un exemple mais typique de comment
on crée la rareté dans le monde
c'est comme un réflexe
vous avez vu sur les buffets à volonté
plus il y a plus on se sert plus on
gaspille et peu importe que ce soit au
détriment des autres le monde va mal à
cause de ce genre d'excès on est huit
milliards à se partager bientôt huit
mignard à se partager la planète
bien sûr qu'elle devient trop petit pour
offrir deux transats par personne je
trouvais ça normal vous que parce que 2
milliards d'entre nous vivent dans le
luxe et l'opulence 6 milliards non plus
de transat
on a perdu la clé si jamais on l'a déjà
trouvé un du vivre ensemble
on est tellement équipe et à vivre
chacun pour soi qu'on ne se soucient
plus les uns des autres
la compétition est devenue la règle de
base
peu importe qu'elles créent la rivalité
au coeur des relations humaines
quant à l'éthique l'équité la justice
sont des très joli concept mais qui ne
tiennent pas la route
quand il s'agit d'intérêts et de profits
je suis coach depuis 2006 et
j'accompagne de plus en plus de gens en
burn out
les chiffres c'est une personne sur
quatre fera un bernabeu dans sa vie et
j'en suis à ma deuxième génération avant
c'était des gens de mon âge qui croyait
dans le système et qui s'épuisait à être
dans le système
aujourd'hui ce sont des jeunes qui ne
peuvent plus y croyez pas déjà dans le
système mais ils ne peuvent plus et ils
ne veulent plus participer à ce système
et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour moi
l'épidémie de burn out est une chanson
elle nous donne la chance de nous
réveiller
elle est comme un signal d'alarmé qui
nous invite à nous reconsidérer chacun
comme des petites planètes plein de
ressources d'eau qui on doit apprendre à
prendre soin comme on doit apprendre à
prendre soin de la grande notre humanité
menacée on doit créer un monde beaucoup
plus organique
partout dans les maisons dans les
entreprises et c'est tout simple il faut
juste se reconnecter à notre
intelligence cellulaire à notre sagesse
physiologique
on a une biologie qui a fait ses preuves
ce fait trois millions d'années qu'elle
s'adapte à notre environnement
on peut faire confiance à cette biologie
et pour moi le grand défi de demain sera
d'apprendre à partager et j'ai une super
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est tous
physiologiquement câblé pour partager
savez vous que la neurobiologie a
découvert qu'on est en connexion
non-stop les uns avec les autres
derrière nos yeux se cache un
gigantesque réseau de neurones miroirs
qui ne sont rien de moins que les
neurones de l'empathie cent mille
millions de neurones miroirs crée sans
cesse des milliers de connexions
si ça c'est pas de la performance notre
cerveau est conçu pour être en lien
non-stop avec le monde mais aussi avec
le monde des autres cerveau et j'ai deux
exemples pour illustrer cette connexion
humaine innée est constante et
inconsciente
c'est le sourire et c'est le bâillement
est rien de plus contagieux vous devez
même pas connaître la personne
vous avez déjà remarqué aussi il suffit
de vous promener dans la rue et si vous
êtes avec un grand sourire et que vous
croiser le regard de quelqu'un il va
s'arrêter et va dire on se connaît c'est
génial on doit vraiment protéger cette
connexion humaine c'est vraiment
important si on veut protéger notre
espèce et pour ça on doit protéger notre
empathie
en fait c'est un sixième sens et il est
le garant de notre humanité et l'os
comme tous nos sens que ce soit le goût
l'odorat cetera il est très fragile et
il peut être pervertie
si mon regard est détournée de toi parce
que je suis trop pressés ou bien je suis
épuisé ou bien je suis fasciné par mes
écrans ou focaliser sur mon nombril
gemain sensibilise du coup tu n'es plus
rien pour moi je ne te calcule plus je
trouve horrible cette expression je ne
te calcule plus ce qui t'arrive
m'indiffère mais par contre si tu
menaces mes intérêts je vais m'arranger
pour me débarrasser de toi par contre si
on prend le temps de se regarder de se
connecter de se mettre en lien les uns
avec les autres
c'est tout magique la connexion elle se
fait automatiquement
mes neurones miroirs me permettent de me
mettre à la place de sentir ce que tu
sens de vivre ce que tu vis on n'est
plus des étrangers et la considération
va réveiller la mienne et si je vois en
fait que tu n'as pas de transat et que
j'en ai deux je vais avoir mes très
naturellement
l' envie de partager
on est tous câblé pour cette empathie
on est tous câblé pour partager alors
pourquoi ce qu'on ne le fait pas parce
que c'est un choix c'est un choix et une
responsabilité de donner de la valeur et
aussi de la chaleur aux gens et pour ça
c'est tout simple il faut reprendre
l'habitude de loving aux yeux et de
regarder autour de nous de regarder ce
qu'ils vivent avec nous trois secondes
de connexion permettent de créer le lien
permettent de créer 7 reliant ce qui
fait que au delà de nos différences on
est tous de la même espèce
alors voilà trois heures que vous êtes
là assis les uns à côté des autres
on va faire une petite expérience ne
vous inquiétez pas ça va pas durer
longtemps et ce sera important de garder
le silence
alors pour ce qu'ils peuvent je vous
propose en fait de vous lever
et de vous tourner vers votre voisin en
prenant soin peut-être en fait que le
maximum de personnes puissent faire
l'expérience est vrai que dans la salle
en fait il ya des rangs un père pour
ceux qui ne peuvent pas fait
l'expérience je vous propose juste de
regarder
est ce qu'on va faire c'est que face à
notre voisin
on va fermer les yeux
respirer connectez-vous à votre
bienveillance à votre sensibilité à mon
signal je vous demanderais d'ouvrir les
yeux et d'accueillir le regard de votre
voisin pendant trois vraies secondes
vous êtes prêts ouvrez les yeux et
rester en silence
vous pouvez fermer les yeux santé à
l'intérieur de vous était ce un exercice
facile ou difficile maintenant vous
pouvez ouvrir les yeux et vous rasseoir
on est un peu plus conscients de la
présence les uns des autres
j'ai envie de terminer par ça l'être
humain est un génie et chacun de ces
progrès a façonné la planète est
aujourd'hui la planète va mal et c'est
pour ça que c'est important de
questionner nos progrès quels sont ceux
qui sont véritablement et honnêtement de
grand pas pour l'humanité
nous venons d'échanger des regards
imaginez que ces regards se multiplient
dans la rue dans le bus dans les maisons
à l'école au bureau dans les réunions
politiques
je suis certaine qu'on prendrait de
meilleures dispositions pour les
personnes et pour la planète et je suis
bien certaine d'une autre chose aussi
c'est qu'on ne trouverait plus le
courage de fermer les yeux de fermer les
portes de fermer les frontières de
dresser des murs pour nous détourner de
nos semblables
le grand progrès de demain est un
progrès qui est à l'intérieur de nous il
s'agit de développer chacun notre
humanité eia
de petits gestes d'attention pas de
petits gestes de considération si on est
des milliers à le faire et je vous passe
le relais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]